boa tarde
em setembro de 2012 13 aliás se há dois
anos atrás eu tive o privilégio de
participar num workshop design thinking
durante três dias três dias que diz
bastante intensivos e foi uma
experiência bastante marcante do que eu
quero partilhar convosco hoje por
coincidência é nessa hora que o shopnow
manhã viram se lançaram um desafio que
era desenhar da participação política
incluindo o voto nas eleições dos jovens
ao nice
isso é uma coincidência porque nós
estamos a cinco dias das nossas eleições
em portugal o que é importante nessa
coincidência é pensarmos que há cerca de
um século atrás quando falávamos design
pensávamos em coisas mais pequenas mas
técnicas produtos e mesmo muito
recentemente no fim do século 20 quando
os designers eram solicitados
era para fazer não só aspectos desenhar
aspectos estéticos mas também coisas
pequenas como o rato do computador se
desenhar a participação política dos
jovens na manhã em portugal é que o que
eu chamo a terceira geração do design é
muito mais centrada no ser humano e isso
tudo em sistemas altamente complexo do
ponto de vista econômico tecnológico e
social e por isso vai falar de design
thinking para percebermos que esta é a
oportunidade de desenhar as nossas
crenças
enquanto seres humanos em contraste cada
vez mais complexo é está omnipresente
todos nós podemos fazer o nas
organizações são trabalhados
e uma característica fundamental do
design thinking é que é extremamente
interdisciplinar e isso é provavelmente
a característica que o pessoalmente mais
gosta e tem muito a ver
conforme se dizia com a nossa vivência
multicultural internacional
se nós pensarmos na quantidade de
equipas que já formamos é possível
perguntarmos virada que essas equipas
tinham ou seja dentro da mesma equipa
até conta que é comum
nós trabalhamos com pessoas de outras
formações outras profissões
outras cidades outras culturas
por isso acredita ele sai ninguém é que
quanto mais diversa é uma equipa melhor
o potencial criativo sistematicamente
falando aí é que nenhum gênio para o
mais é individual por mais criativo que
seja pode superar essa do poder criativo
de uma equipe interdisciplinar porque
nós somos diferentes
pensamos de forma diferente a que chama
colisões criativas pensamento divergente
ou se quiserem pensamento fora da caixa
além disso o design thinking assenta num
processo que é relativamente sistemático
não vou chamar ciência da criatividade
mas a provável é que nós tivemos também
há mais de um século com exemplos como
matemático francês henri que eu próprio
conhecia quando tentava resolver os seus
problemas matemáticos por mais que se
esforçasse não os conseguir resolver a
primeira mas esse esforço era
compensavam quando depois algum
distanciamento outro miro ou passear
a solução surgiu há quase trinta
elementos e pôde verificar e e ficava
surpreendido pela solução de fato está
correta e eu achava que isso era um
padrão publicou no início do século 20
imagina o único o thomaz é de sangue
também dizia que 99% da que atirava é
transpiração
só 1% é que inspira se nos juntarmos à
nossa volta em diferentes equipas
pessoas
frente se seguirmos um tribunal no
processo como é que os judeus do design
thinking porque há muitos com mais ou
menos fácil nos propõe
talvez aumentamos o nosso potencial
criativo que era nível local quer a
nível internacional e que temos um
exemplo 35 opções todo mundo que
formaram na altura sete equipas cinco
pessoas e corremos um processo e eu
quero partilhar convosco algumas ideias
sobre esse processo ea forma como vocês
podem aplicá lo nas nossas organizações
a primeira é a primeira fase
se quiserem e da compreensão ou seja em
vez de saltar os pais funções com muitas
vezes temos a tentação de fazer 80 anos
em inglês hosts manter a calma e acima
de tudo
contextualizado o desafio 19 sábado
lembrou se do nosso desafio a desenhar a
participação política dos jovens
isto vai dar muitas questões por que
jovens não participam mais das eleições
porque os jovens não voto em ninguém
nesta fase mais uma vez não é preciso
ser genial nem é preciso fazer
investigação científica porém dura basta
perguntar nos com base nas experiências
dos membros da equipa porque que isso
será assim os quiserem fazer pesquisas
que são fáceis de fazer online para é
encontrar dicas pistas porque é que há
esta ausência de participação
uma segunda fase é mais trabalho de
campo tem mais a ver com trabalho tempo
e essa é uma parte de santíssima porque
nós olharmos à nossa volta nem sempre
nós vamos à realidade e falar com as
pessoas é e portanto neste caso podem
ver as equipas nas ruas pode ficar na
unha é falar com os jovens é perguntar
diretamente em vez de assumir isto ou
aquilo é falar diretamente com base em
ninguém
um perguntas feitas a partir daquela
investigação inicial o é mas ainda é
melhor perguntar às pessoas porque é que
se comporta da forma que comportam e
observá las porque o ser humano em
província imenso ser humano súbito
quando têm problemas
cria e usa muitos à tarde
e portanto nós queremos ser realistas e
melhor ainda observar o comportamento em
vez de perguntar às pessoas e forçá los
a pensar naquilo que fazem coxim ee
surgem muitas oportunidades de cidades
que nem sequer as pessoas conseguem
articular mas são evidentes quando
quando olhamos pra elas
a terceira fase em fazer uma simples
destes dois primeiros passos ou seja nós
fizemos investigação preliminar fomos
fizemos trabalho de campo e agora é
preciso identificar diferentes pontos de
vista sempre numa lógica de fugir a esse
ponto isso é muito importante porque é
que entra uma parte muito humana do
design thinking obriga-nos a colocar no
lugar do outro
neste caso da que os jovens voltam ou
não o voto e que muito interessantes
pensar que muitas vezes são aquilo que
nós chamamos os casos extremos que são
mais interessantes ou seja não
procuramos a representatividade
estatística da maioria da população
porque isso é o que o mundo é hoje que
nós queremos é criar um mundo que ainda
não existe nos deram um exemplo das
nossas malas de viagem com robinho
elas foram criadas não porque a maioria
da população se lembrou que robinho nas
malas nos preocupa e utiliza dois
extremos com os pilotos do avião que
mais usavam as malas sentir a velocidade
dessa dessa prova das farinhas e
portanto nós aqui procuramos um contexto
de utilizar os extremos porque o
objetivo inspiração para criar coisas
novas equipes aqui pode ser bastante
inclusive bastante local a idéia é que
seja sempre a pensar naquelas pessoas
que não estão ainda incluídas nessa e
nas políticas e nos sistemas atuais
a quarta fase é fácil criticar a
prancheta da geração de idéias e que o
mais importante em novembro com o site
em podermos
é gerar tantas idéias quanto possível
sem qualquer tipo de disposto a partida
e portanto um com técnicas como
bem-estar brindes da bob store man
vamos fugir dessas idéias
há uma ideia que possa ser estava e que
outra parte muito concreto do design
thinking e o fax protótipo para as
idéias nos protótipos de idéias para ser
já um último moveu do que vai fazer em
termos técnicos no futuro isso faço mais
perto do fim do projeto mas numa fase
inicial só para comunicar o caso nós não
conseguiu explicar até das ideias que
temos nem é possível receber um feedback
tanque neste caso nós fizemos um
protótipo de uma aplicação informática
com base numa cidade que encontramos de
jovens que não tinham informação sobre
os candidatos às eleições sobre seus
programas quando não falavam dos seus
temas de interesse nem consigam
acompanhar se as promessas eram
efetivamente cumpridas ao longo do
mandato
e finalmente a última fase é fácil do
texto ou seja serem as pessoas mesmo sem
nós explicarmos um protótipo
intuitivamente que compreenderam não
compreender é que o que nós temos aqui
no estado nós propusemos uma aplicação
que permite se como palavra-chave
facilmente 11 11 um jovem por ver e
comparar seu receber informação sobre
cadeiradas os seus programas e
acompanhar a legislação ao longo do
mandato político sobre os temas
isto é uma nova forma de resolver
problemas que vêm sobretudo humanos num
no ambiente complexidade tecnológica e
tanto públicas quer é hoje a a
administração pública como exemplo que
os dae mas também empresas e
instituições sem fins lucrativos
eu quero dar um exemplo aqui uma empresa
americana pan am ball que é muito
conhecida por que em seis anos duplicou
as vendas mas não só não são quaisquer
vendas nós pensarmos de 40 para 80
milhões e mil milhões de dólares estamos
a falar de volumes muito grande porque
este estudo
quando lá foi acreditava no design
ninguém por ter vivido no japão muito
tempo e portanto criou o primeiro lugar
vai se o presidente for design é da
empresa na história da empresa é com
esta senhora chamada cláudia caótica e
uma coisa muito importante ferramenta
acompanhar com indicadores de desempenho
este é este projecto é outro exemplo da
pepsi o grupo da pepsi que descobriu
deverá por indra nooy que é uma senhora
que descobriu com a ajuda do douro
porcini o primeiro designer shift 1907
da empresa que as mulheres consomem
dúvidas e equipes de forma completamente
enfrenta os anos que nos dizem não basta
pink toshin rich franklin no sentido de
que não basta ser mais fluido é preciso
conhecer que as pessoas que conformam se
comportam de forma diferente e último
exemplo tirar é português é nova base
maior grupo de tecnologias de informação
which paulo salvado e o pedro januário
também responsável pelo design da
empresa já formaram mais de mil pessoas
na nova base eu já falava em com o apoio
até da claudia óptica é que em portugal
porque as pessoas sejam mais
cooperativas e um dos pontos mais
interessantes da nova base e os
reconhecerem que por serem em uma
empresa centrada em projetos tenham um
comportamento bastante competitivo por
vezes e entre os próprios colegas iam
usar avisar ninguém para criar mais
cooperação entre as pessoas
isso leva a minha última volta consegui
nada contra a ex equipe provavelmente
uma forma de incluir o tema deste tex e
competição e transformar um braço de
ferro no aperto na praia